Jurassic Park 3 is not directed by
Steven Spielberg it's actually directed
by Joe Johnston and it stars Sam Neill
William H Maci and Taylor yoni and is
the continuation of the Jurassic Park
series and it's where the series kind of
went downhill for a lot of people and
myself included now if you guys didn't
know I already reviewed the lost world
in anticipation for the upcoming
Jurassic world and Jurassic Park 3d when
it came out a couple years ago so I'm
now completing my series of Jurassic
reviews because I just I'm a
completionist and just in case you
haven't seen JP 3 I suggest checking out
that movie first and then coming back
and watching the review because there
are gonna be spoilers throughout this
video so the story of this movie is
basically we need to get Sam Neill back
on the island for some reason so we have
a boy who crashed lands when he's
parasailing and this family lies to Sam
Neill to get him to the island because
they're telling him we just need you to
be our guide but in reality it's the
boy's parents they have no money and
they get sam neill thereby offering him
money just like in the first movie again
the motivation for going there is money
in the lost world the motivation for
Jeff Goldblum returning to the island
was love his girlfriend was on that
island so he had an emotional reason for
going back to the island in this movie
it's because somebody writes a lot of
zeros on a cheque so you instantly don't
really care that much but right off the
bat in the opening scene of this movie I
watched it today I could not believe how
painfully excruciatingly ly obvious the
green-screen is the characters who are
parasailing in the foreground and then
the background of the ocean and the
mountains are like on a completely
different color scheme it's really bad
and that's just the first issue with the
CGI in this movie and one of the biggest
reasons I think it doesn't work is
because Joe Johnston and the special
effects team decided to utilize a lot of
close-ups of CGI dinosaurs now if you go
back and watch Jurassic Park and the
lost world close-up shots of dinosaurs
were almost exclusively animatronic any
time a dinosaur was right next to a
person's head or right in frame with the
camera it was almost 99.9 percent of the
time an animatronic
CGI was mostly utilized for wide shots
because you're not closely examining
these computer details that Spielberg in
is too
minou just weren't up to par for that
type of filmmaking but in Jurassic Park
3 there are tons of detailed close-ups
of CGI dinosaurs and they don't hold up
any more it's great to see Sam Neill
back he's probably the best part of this
movie I love him as the character of
Alan Grant his introduction where he's
playing with the two dinosaur toys which
by the way our spinosaurus and a t-rex
who will later fight in the movie
interesting little easter egg there I
love that he's explaining to the child
that he's making the wrong types of
dinosaurs fight because the kid is
playing with herbivores and he's like
those wouldn't fight that wouldn't
happen I just I love how it's just like
he's looking at this little kid this is
perfect it's perfect Alan Grant writing
right there and it's also nice to see
Laura Dern back as Ellie but they made
them break up for some reason so it kind
of lessens the impact of the first
Jurassic Park it's basically like we
want Sam Neill back but Laura Dern can't
return and so we'll write her into this
little part and we'll make him break up
and it just lessens that fun of the
first film because you know it's like
okay they're not going to end up
together so why like why would you do
that to the characters it's similar to
at the start of alien 3 spoilers for
alien 3 they kill off certain characters
that made it at the end of aliens and
you're like why that kind of lessens the
impact of aliens now they did the same
thing with this one so once they finally
convinced Sam Neill to go to this island
they have a scene in which his friend
Billy describes his lucky pack unlike
another lucky pack Sarah Harding had a
lucky pack in the lost world you're
really going to write another character
who has a lucky pack that's just lazy
writing you just did that
exact same thing in the last film and of
course the scene with the plane going to
the island that's probably the dumbest
scene in the entire franchise even
dumber than when the little girl does a
gymnastics bit in lost world
we have Alan having his Raptor dream in
which a raptor looks at him and goes
Alan Alan and then he wakes up from a
dream it's like what was the point of
having a startling Raptor dream where
the Raptor said his name let it that's
really that's really dumb that's not
good the other super disappointing thing
for me when I rewatched this movie was
the characters they're not entertaining
they're poorly written
nothing really interesting about them
except for Alan grant and a lot of that
is because we love sam neill as Alan
Grant from the first film and he's so
good as that character but talionis
screaming and flailing around constantly
and William H Macy making really
terrible jokes that just fall flat it
didn't work at all in the character of
Billy
well likable is such a boring and dull
character and once we do finally meet
their son it's like okay he's kind of a
cool character he's resourceful he was
able to survive for like eight weeks by
himself and Trevor Morgan who betrayed
him was clearly right in that time
period where his voice was kind of
changing so whenever he screams his
looks like they over by the river that's
what I say my other issue are we
watching it and I can't believe actually
how many issues I had because I haven't
watched this movie in years I really
didn't like this movie the animatronics
aren't even really that good the
spinosaurus creature really feels like a
machine it feels like a theme-park
machine that would be on the Universal
Studios ride the animatronics in the
first two films were mind-blowing they
melded seamlessly with the CGI in this
movie it's like this hydraulically
controlled spinosaurus creature that
just looks like a machine going back and
forth it's not good anymore guys it
really looks dated and the t-rex versus
Spinosaurus fight we were all excited to
see was like 20 seconds long if even
that it was so disappointing but one of
my biggest flaws with Jurassic Park 3 is
that there actually isn't really a clear
antagonist Spinosaurus doesn't count
that thing just shows up every once in a
while to chase them and then they get
behind something and block it from
getting to them that's pretty much the
whole movie they run from things get to
a safe spot and then they run from
something else and get to a safe spot
it's just like a 92 minute with credits
thriller that just did not fit into the
Jurassic Park world it's 92 minutes how
crazy is that I mean all the other ones
are over two hours long if you like this
awesome adventure this one is just like
this little TV episode or something of
Jurassic Park but like I said the
antagonist in the movie there aren't any
there is not a single human antagonist
in this movie it should have been the
Kirby's think about it this couple lied
to Alan Grant and to his friend Billy
and to all the mercenaries they hired
about their position about their worth
about everything got them to the most
dangerous place on earth just because
they're looking for their son which I
understand their emotional motivation
but they really should have been the
villains of this movie they should have
made them a lot less lighthearted there
should have been serious confrontation
and maybe even hate brewing between
these people but it's all played for
comedy and you're just supposed to
accept this couple who got a lot of
people killed and seriously injured
simply because they were looking for
their son are the good guys they should
have been the antagonists of Jurassic
Park 3 how much more interesting of a
film would that have been but do you
want to know the dumbest part of this
movie there's a scene where they find
the video camera that the kid had when
he was parasailing the battery is dead
and one of their friends comes over
takes a flashlight and says I have an
idea he starts to unravel the flashlight
and cut to the camera just working now
let's talk about that a little bit this
is a camera similar to the camera used
in Jurassic Park 3 it's an old-ass video
camera this is the cameras battery it
goes in the back right there
this is a d-cell flashlight battery I
don't think it fucking works we're
supposed to believe that they hooked up
little wires to this battery and somehow
charged the camera battery with the
different voltage and everything if
Spielberg K made this movie who would
have been like look a whole bunch of
people who watch my films are huge film
buffs are directors people who love
filmmaking they're gonna know that a
d-cell flashlight battery is not going
to work on that shitty little 1999 video
camera now yes I know guys before you
tell me there are ways to hook up little
wires and stuff there are YouTube videos
out there that show you how to charge a
camera with a d-cell battery but do you
really think they're going to have any
of that material on this easel of sorna
island where they're lost and there's
dinosaurs just give me a break okay give
me a break writers and once the Raptors
finally do show up for some reason this
rap
or decides to pull an ET and hide behind
the glass without moving and then it
jumps out at tay leone I'm like really
what there's just no theme to this movie
the first two films had a theme man
nature don't meddle with it stay away
from it don't get involved bad stuff
happens this movie is just a series of
scenes in which people run away from
dinosaurs that's it now I read two
things on the IMDB trivia that really
interested me for one it states that the
film began shooting before the script
was completed well that answers a lot of
things and also apparently in the
original script Billy's character does
die when the Pteranodons attack him and
everything but he protested and Joe
Johnston allowed him to be alive at the
end because he gave in to his actors
stupid demands and once we finally get
to the big end scene where the raptors
really want these Raptor eggs from them
that they stole apparently Alan Grant is
just able to somehow mimic a perfect
Raptor call with this thing that he has
he's like and then the Raptors look
uh-huh Paul Paul and they all start
running away it's like wow that's a
skilled man
and what's the Navy and Marines show up
they've somehow already found Billy
alive he's on the chopper the
Pteranodons are flying next to them at
the end the same Pteranodons that
attacked them and are now loose and
they're all like oh look how beautiful
they are flying yeah oh look at they
just tried to kill us like 20 minutes
ago
so Jurassic Park 3 was a very
disappointing movie for me a lot of the
story elements didn't make sense the
characters were boring there was no
clear antagonist there wasn't much to
the characters in regards to any type of
emotional conflict it was just run from
big CGI dinosaurs that look fake it's so
incredible to believe the movies made in
1993 in 1997 had better special effects
in the one made in 2001 I'm gonna give
Jurassic Park 3 a c-minus it's great to
see Sam Neill back it has some
entertaining scenes but for the most
part this movie was vastly disappointing
so guys I am super excited to bring you
my review of Jurassic world I'm going to
be seeing it on June
I can't wait to see it I hope it's great
I hope it's great please be good and if
you guys miss my review of the lost
world that is on my channel right now as
well as an older review of Jurassic Park
3d but still acceptable I hope you guys
enjoy that as well thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
my niced